i really love
how you co-parent and
you have been a major
beacon of just how it can
be done because no
parent on earth probably signs up to
have kids
and then wants to you know have
the plan change how did you know
to do this in this way i mean you
literally gave
a euphemism for divorce that makes us
all feel like we're saying it with
a flare of dignity and hope
thank you how did you take something
broken and fix it
i mean it's so interesting because like
in a way
my divorce and my relationship with
chris now is like better than our
marriage was
so i do think that it can be done i
think you know their needs
i i was i was really lucky because i had
a doctor who
kind of gave us a rubric for how to do
it and luckily he's writing a book
and i think it's coming up next year
thank goodness
um and because it really kind of lays
out the tenets of how you do it and it's
a little bit
unsurprising right it's like you have to
have
radical accountability you have to know
that
every relationship is 50 50. no matter
what you think how you think you were
wronged
or you know how bad you perceive the
other person's actions or whatever the
case may be
if you are brave enough to take
responsibility for your half
and really look at your own garbage and
your own trauma and how it's presenting
in the world
and in your relationship then there's
really somewhere to go
and something to learn and something to
heal and then also you're
also holding the other person in
[Music]
this sphere of humanity like we're all
part good in part bad it's not binary
we're all gray area we all are trying
our best
and i really wanted my
kids to not be traumatized if it were
possible
chris and i committed to putting them
first and that's
harder than it looks because some days
you really don't want to be with the
person that you're
getting divorced from but if you're
committed to having family dinner then
you do it
and you take a deep breath and you look
the person in the eye
and you remember your pact and you smile
and you hug and you make
a joke and you just recommit to this new
relationship that you are trying to
foster
none of us want to get it wrong for our
kids
but just because of what happened in the
marriage
is not about the parenting this is about
their relationship with their dad
and their mom not about their
relationship with your marriage
you know you said it it's like you're
ending a marriage
but you're still in a family like that's
how it will be forever some days it's
not as
good as it looks you know like we also
have good days and bad days but i think
it's driving towards the same purpose of
unity and and love and really what's
best for them and
we have this idea that just because we
break up we can't love
the things about the person anymore that
we loved and that's not true
i've always seen you from afar and
wished
to know you and then it was like finally
our timing came together and i just
thank god
marvel at you by the way you are the
best planner
the most cool friend the best sense of
humor i
die over you and i would be
uh totally selfish to just love up on
you and not get like
any insider goop information not to take
a turn tonally but is there any exciting
news or things you want to tell us
so that we may better the outside after
we've talked
about how we take care of our insides
and our hearts what's the 4-1-1
well i have been spending
you know quarantine's been a very
interesting time i think for all of us
and you know obviously it's been
pretty horrific in a lot of ways but i
think there has been this wonderful
silver lining of this beautiful
insularity at home and with
our kids and our our loved ones
and um but no traveling no rushing
around so it's sort of time to sit it's
been time to sit with yourself
and um so i had sort of like recommitted
to
a few things to feel better like my
meditation practice which
had been so sporadic and um
making sure to move every single day no
matter what and
like trying to be good with hydration
and everything
and then but my one little beauty tip
that since i was doing so many zooms
all i could see was like these brown
lines that i was
coming here um and
i'm really lucky because one of my
closest friends is a plastic surgeon his
name is julius and he lives in chicago
and i'm always asking him like
what what's the thing coming down the
road and he gave me a teeny drop
of this thing called xeomin which is
a purified wrinkle anti-wrinkle
injection and i just feel like
it was purified it's like a pure
uniquely purified formula so i felt like
okay this is in the wellness
world and it was it was a zoom
face cure for me
[Music]